so samsung just briefly announced the
brand new
samsung galaxy zed fold 2.
is it the perfect phone for architects
in 2020
today we're going to find out
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel
if you're new here thank you so much for
joining me like i said my name is david
tomic
i'm a masters of architecture graduate
and i'm an entrepreneur
i've started multiple businesses across
the years
and i've also invested in many other
things first and foremost i design
beautiful homes and commercial
architecture for a living so today i
really wanted to focus on
the zed fold too to see if it is the
perfect utensil
for architects across the world so
before we get right into this video
quick life
update yes i'm still in crutches yes i'm
still in a cast
for those of you who don't know i
ruptured my achilles tendon a couple
weeks ago
and i have my specialist appointment at
the end of this week
so far all good i've just been in the
cast and mobilized
can't really do much getting around on
the crutches the good thing is i've
still been able to go to work and i've
still been able to make these youtube
videos so i think that deserves that you
smash that like button
and help this video with the youtube
algorithm so first of all
it has been announced by samsung
officially but it also
hasn't been announced by samsung
officially on september 1st
they will be announcing all the specs
all the bells and whistles that come
along with it
today we only have the general
understanding of what it is
what it's capable of and potentially
what we're going to find out on
september 1st
however the theory and the concept
remain very strong
and remain exactly the same so let's
talk about the specs that we actually
do know so far the samsung zedfold 2
comes in a beautiful new design so the
old samsung fold
1 had a much smaller front screen the
front screen on the samsung zed fold 2
now is immersive it takes up the entire
space it's 6.2 inches
bezel to bezel and then when you unfold
the device it is
7.6 inches bezel to bezel so if you were
to compare this to an ipad mini
which is 7.9 inches it is a very
similar size and shape the one advantage
here you have
is straight away it's a 120 hertz
amoled display and if you're not
familiar with 120 hertz
it's significantly smoother and a lot
more user friendly to use
your eyes immediately recognize the
difference so once you make the switch
to 120
from 60 you'll definitely be happy that
you did on the back we can see it
features a triple camera setup
but they don't tell us what these specs
are yet we can however determine it's
going to be very similar to the note 20
series
which means a 12 megapixel ultra wide
camera
a 12 megapixel wide camera and a 64
megapixel
telephoto lens it doesn't appear that
there's any
laser focusing sensors on the back of
this device not in the renders at least
so we probably won't get the camera
features from the note 20 ultra
just the original note 20 series the big
thing that destroyed the zed fold one
was the fact it wasn't dust resistant
water resistant
or basically life proof at all people
started peeling off the screens as soon
as they got it and destroyed it
so that really set samsung back we have
no information if
this one is going to be dust proof
waterproof but they have said it is
more life proof now so we're hoping it's
going to be a little bit more robust
the zed fold 2 comes in two color
options mystic black
and mystic bronze the mystic bronze is
the one that they've been displaying and
pushing very hard
and i'm sure it will do very well across
the world however personally
i will be picking the mystic black
unfolded it is only
six millimeters thin that is an
incredibly
thin device the s20 ultra what i'm
filming on
right now is 8.8 millimeters and once
you put a cover
on it it's probably somewhere closer to
10 or 11
which means when you fold the samsung
zed fold to
it's only going to be in the ranges of
12 to 15 millimeters thick
that's actually not too bad especially
if you're one of those people that's
used to carrying
one of those big clunky wallet cases i'm
not a fan but
if you are it's probably still thinner
than that itself
okay so enough about the specs why do i
think this is
the perfect device for architects in the
world right now in 2020 well it's the
best of both worlds it's a phone
and a tablet at the exact same time that
means you have
the luxury and liberty of using either
or device
and never having to forget one or the
other when you're in sight or when
you're meeting with a client you can
easily pull out your phone
unfold it start drawing on it start
writing notes
or doing whatever you need like you
would on your normal tablet it would be
nice to see
the dex feature incorporated into the
zed fold too
which would allow it to turn into more
of a pc style device
but i think that will probably be only
available to when you actually do plug
it into a computer the triple camera
setup on the back also gives you the
luxury and liberty
of photographing everything you need on
site be it the whole room
finer details or just the generic site
photo
i found that ever since i upgraded to
the s20 ultra i no longer carry around
my big heavy dslr in fact i actually
sold it and got rid of it
now i use the s20 ultra to capture all
my site photos and even
all my marketing photos the ultra wide
lens on the rear
captures the entire room which is
perfect for getting those marketing
shots or just getting
everything in the one shot the main
camera is fantastic
capturing those in the live moments or
just perfect details then you have the
telephoto lens which also has that
ability
of really getting up close and personal
with some textures
so all three cameras combined is like
having a full
dslr kit in your back pocket so samsung
galaxy
zenfold 2 is the perfect
drawing device it's a dual tablet
phone it has a triple camera what else
do you want i think that definitely
deserves
you smashing the like button having said
this i don't think it is
the perfect device for architects just
yet
and let me explain i said that it's the
perfect device for taking notes
and drawing in front of your clients but
unfortunately
there is no s pen or any sort of stylus
device that accompanies it
there is no generic accessory that
they've unveiled that goes with this
device
i think it would be perfect accessory if
it had
the note 20 style s pen built into the
bottom
and it just clicked out whenever you
needed it that is
definitely something i'll be looking
forward to in the next version of this
zedfold 2
if that feature ever comes out for this
device so without the s pen i think that
it kind of limits you to what you can do
on the tablet itself
yes you can still type notes and you can
draw with your hands but
it's not the same as using a physical
pen i use the apple pencil all the time
on my ipad and i think it is the best
purchase i've made to date
for this device so having that accessory
would put this device in a whole other
category also we don't know if this
phone is
water or dust resistant yet so going on
site
being around builders around tradies
with
the dust everywhere things flying around
most of the time it's sand it's dirt
it's
water especially if it's raining you
don't want this device which is probably
going to range upwards of 2
000 australian dollars to get destroyed
on the first day you go
on site you'll probably look pretty
silly if you pull out your super
expensive phone
unfold it all the dust gets in and it's
gone
so you really don't want this happening
to your device and until it is
fully water resistant and dust resistant
there's probably going to be a few
issues with taking this phone on site
now i mentioned the triple camera setup
on the back
being a luxury feature for anybody out
in the field
the s20 ultra that i use now has a
premium
camera bump on the back the fold 2
apparently is not going to have those
premium specs
so yes you're going to get decent photos
and everything you need
but you're definitely not going to get
those dslr quality
high-res images that you're really
looking for and finally
i do think this device is the way of the
future but at the moment
it is still probably a little bit too
small to be used as a practical device
at 7.6 inches it's definitely too small
an ipad mini isn't something you can
really use practically on a day-to-day
basis
for something that requires a lot of
graphic
kind of design elements to it i think in
my personal opinion 10.5 inches
the ipad itself ipad ipad as they call
it
is probably the perfect size so if this
device were able to
expand to such a large uh screener
display
that would again make this device so
much better
so just to recap i think that this
device is amazing
but i don't think it's the perfect
device for architects to throw away
all their phones and their tablets just
yet when it gets a little bit more
refined
is dust proof and waterproof potentially
has that
s pen inside it and is a little bit
bigger
on the unfolded display then i think
this device is going to be incredible
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button 2020 style
hit the like button to help the
algorithm and as always
i'll see you next monday